a studio apartment in the big city a
small and strange environment this human
has boldly traveled far from a natural
countryside habitat but is not as
adapted to this harsh alien world it
threatens her instinctual behavior her
ears are assaulted like a cacophony of
the city
throwing author equilibrium and
concentration and the blinding rays of
unnatural light penetrate her eyelids if
he can't make her nest feel safe she
won't sleep and not sleeping can lead to
higher stress levels and a greater risk
of depression something must be done
daybreak she works quickly to transform
her habitat into a more healthy and
restful home gathering soft materials to
line her nest
research shows in organized living space
can increase productivity and help you
sleep better and she improves her space
by bringing life to the formal a
lifeless ecosystem houseplants can
improve concentration and productivity
as well as reduce stress levels and
boost mood victorious she displays a
warrior's pose and prepares for
tomorrow's busy workday with a great
night's sleep
[Music]